À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Nos héros sont en plein tournoi
dans le Japon féodal de 1150.
S'ils gagnent, ils pourront
récupérer la 3ème relique
du Docteur Simon,
ce qui leur permettra enfin
de le retrouver.
Malheureusement,
le pirate la Buse
et Eliot le robot
ont été éliminés.
Et tout le poids de la mission
se retrouve
sur les épaules frêles
de Thomas.
Parce que oui, Thomas
est toujours dans l'aventure.
C'est fou, non ?
Attendez, c'est moi qui dois
me battre contre le samouraï ?
Je l'aurais bien fait
à ta place,
mais le règlement interdit
les femmes de participer.
J'ai toujours été
pour l'égalité homme-femme,
surtout si ça peut m'éviter
de mourir sur un ring.
C'est ma faute, les des-amis.
J'ai perdu à un combat.
Et ça m'était jamais arrivé !
Pendant toute ma vie,
j'ai gagné !
17 ans de victoires !
T'as 17 ans ?
Tu les fais pas du tout.
C'est parce que j'ai encore
un œil valide.
Ça me rajeunit.
Bon, de toute façon,
on pouvait pas prévoir tout ça.
C'est pas de votre faute si...
Mais qu'est-ce qui lui arrive,
à l'autre, là ?
Ça va, Eliot ?
Snif.
Pourquoi il a dit "snif" ?
Il bugue ou quoi ?
Je crois que notre frère de
métal est en train de pleurer.
T'inquiète pas,
ça m'est arrivé aussi.
Une fois, à ma naissance,
mais le répétez pas, hein !
Mais Eliot ne peut pas pleurer,
c'est une machine à café.
Techniquement,
je ne peux pas pleurer.
Mais je suis
quand même triste, Iris.
Snif supplémentaire.
Mais t'es triste de quoi ?
De plus avoir de touillettes
en stock ?
- C'est drôle, non ?
- T'es dure, Iris.
Je suis triste
parce que c'est de ma faute
si on ne retrouvera jamais
le Docteur Simon.
- Et que Thomas va mourir.
- Quoi ?
Mais ça, ça va,
j'arrive à gérer.
Donc en fait, je vais mourir ?
Quand je suis arrivé
dans votre famille, Iris,
j'ai tout de suite compris
où était ma place.
Dans la cuisine,
entre Gérard et Murielle.
- Euh... Qui sont ?
-Le frigo et le lave-vaisselle.
Il faut s'intéresser
au petit personnel, Iris.
Ouh là là, pardon !
Et si on revenait
sur le fait que je vais mourir ?
Moi, ça m'intéresse.
Le Professeur Simon
a toujours été gentil avec moi.
Il est le père
que j'ai toujours voulu avoir.
Alors que toi, Iris,
sa vraie fille,
tu ne voulais pas de lui.
C'est triste, non ?
Pas aussi triste
que ma mort imminente.
Quand il a disparu
et qu'il m'a appelé,
je me suis dit : ça y est,
c'est mon heure de gloire.
Je vais le retrouver
et il me dira :
"Merci, fiston."
Oh, ça y est, je pleure.
Me regardez pas ou je vous tue !
Je suis désolée, Eliot,
je savais pas.
Personne est désolé de savoir
que je vais mourir, par contre.
Bon, écoutez-moi.
Personne ne va mourir
et on va gagner ce tournoi, OK ?
Et puis on va récupérer
la dernière relique
et retrouver mon père,
et ça, c'est grâce à toi, Eliot.
Parce que t'es pas qu'un robot.
Maintenant, t'es un...
- Un des-ami !
- Voilà, un des-ami !
Merci.
Fin du mode tristesse.
Début du mode
reprise de confiance en soi.
Ah, je suis content d'apprendre
que je vais pas mourir !
Et j'ai hâte de savoir
comment c'est possible.
Thomas, si tu utilises ta force
face à ce samouraï,
tu vas mourir.
OK, c'est pas du tout
ce que je voulais entendre.
La seule façon pour toi
de gagner le match,
c'est de pousser le samouraï
hors du ring, OK ?
Euh... je sais faire ça, moi ?
C'est pour ça qu'il faut
que tu t'entraînes,
genre beaucoup.
Le match est dans 5 minutes !
Oui, j'apprends vite.
Oui, j'ai fini Sniper Elite 4
sans les tutos,
mais quand même.
On peut voyager dans le temps,
je vous rappelle.
On peut passer des heures
à s'entraîner où on veut
et quand on veut.
OK, donc la question, c'est :
où et quand
apprendre à pousser
quelqu'un très fort ?
Quelqu'un de dos,
ça m'arrangerait.
Quelqu'un qui mérite
qu'on le pousse
des centaines de fois
sans ressentir de culpabilité ?
Je vais ouvrir
un peu plus grand pour...
Bon, t'as vu comment j'ai fait,
Thomas ?
- Ouais.
- À toi, maintenant.
Eliot, on recommence.
- Vas-y, Thomas !
- OK, j'y vais.
Pour profiter du soleil...
Oh non, j'ai ripé,
il est pas tombé !
Vous avez essayé
de me pousser, nein ?
Ce n'est pas très gentil,
tout ça.
- Finis-le, Thomas !
- Je le fais !
Mais qu'est-ce que vous...
Quelle sensation agréable !
Oh ouais, c'est cool, hein,
de pousser Hitler d'un balcon ?
C'est qui, Hitler ?
Bah, c'est...
Ah bah oui, c'est vrai,
tu peux pas le connaître.
C'est la 1ère fois
que je voyais ce petit bonhomme.
Et tu l'as poussé comme ça,
sans savoir pourquoi ?
Moi, quand je vois quelqu'un
près d'une fenêtre,
je le pousse,
c'est dans ma nature.
Ah, bah,
on va éviter de s'approcher
trop près du bord, alors.
Eliot, on repart en arrière !
Thomas,
sois ferme sur tes appuis.
- Allez, vas-y, Thomas !
- OK.
- Super, Thomas, yes !
- Merci.
Allez, on y retourne.
- En appui sur le pied gauche !
- OK.
- C'est bien, mon bonhomme !
- Plus rapide, Thomas !
OK, plus rapide.
1, 2, 3,
bien en appui, go !
OK, tu t'améliores, Thomas !
On y retourne. Eliot ?
- Allez, Thomas !
- OK, j'y vais.
Mais arrêtez !
Euh, c'est bizarre,
il a dit un truc nouveau, là.
C'est impossible : chaque fois
qu'on remonte dans le temps,
la réalité redémarre.
Allez, on y retourne !
Imagine que c'est un samouraï,
maintenant !
- OK. Au revoir, le samouraï !
- Non mais ça suffit !
J'ai l'impression qu'il sait
qu'on le pousse à chaque fois.
C'est vraiment bizarre.
On recommence.
- Thomas, tu dois être prêt.
- OK.
Ça alors, il est plus là !
C'est anormal.
Hitler a disparu de la pièce.
Où tu te caches,
petit bonhomme à moustache ?
Bon, on n'a plus personne
à pousser...
Fin de l'entraînement !
Eliot, on retourne
à notre tournoi.
OK, je pense
que je me sens prêt.
Je peux le pousser.
Et...
c'est parti pour la finale !
Takeshi, le grand samouraï
et la fierté de la nation,
contre Thomas...
Juste, euh, Thomas.
Les adversaires se saluent,
et...
que le meilleur gagne !
- OK, je suis prêt.
- Vas-y, Thomas !
- Je vais le faire.
- Pousse-le, Thomas !
J'y vais !
Il aurait dû pousser
son adversaire, non ?
Pas seulement rebondir
contre lui.
Contrairement à Hitler,
le samouraï est très lourd.
90 kg de muscles,
plus une armure.
C'est plus dur, du coup.
Tu m'étonnes !
Le samouraï a même pas bougé.
Aïe, avec son armure, il m'a
fait super mal aux mains !
Regardez, c'est tout rouge !
La charge de Thomas
n'a pas suffi.
Et maintenant, c'est Takeshi
qui sort lentement son katana,
il s'approche de Thomas,
qui est figé de peur !
Me tuez pas !
Thomas ?
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Il semblerait que Thomas
se recroqueville par terre
et sur le côté.
Thomas, relève-toi !
Thomas est en position fœtale.
Il avance sa main
près de son visage,
il sort son pouce, et...
Eh oui !
Il le met à sa bouche
pour le téter !
Oh, mon Dieu !
Mais qu'est-ce que je vois là ?
Non ? Mais si !
C'est bien de l'urine
qui coule de son pantalon !
Vous allez peut-être
la goûter, celle-là, non ?
Ça va, avec cette histoire !
- Oh merde, c'est trop triste !
- Et terriblement gênant.
Je propose qu'on ne dise pas
à sa mère comment il est mort.
On dira qu'il est tombé
d'une falaise en jouant à...
Pokémon Go.
C'est plus noble.
Adieu, petit matelot
chétif et imberbe.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Takeshi, le grand samouraï,
est figé,
son katana à la main...
Il ne donne pas
le coup de grâce.
Oh, attendez, attendez !
Je crois qu'il va dire
quelque chose.
Ce n'est pas un combattant,
c'est un enfant !
J'ai déshonoré mon clan
en me battant contre lui.
Je ne mérite pas de vivre !
Oh là là !
Takeshi retourne
la lame contre lui !
Takeshi se hara-kiri !
Ses boyaux tombent au sol !
Takeshi s'effondre !
Il est mort !
Attendez, quoi ?
Une défaite par hara-kiri,
comme on en a...
déjà vu, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais tout à fait.
C'est vrai que dans notre pays,
on ne se suicide pas
avec le dos de la cuillère.
Et Thomas remporte
la relique ancestrale
confiée par le grand esprit
au manteau aussi blanc...
- On a gagné !
- Que la cime du mont Fuji !
Ainsi qu'un magnifique
porte-clés en bronze !
Sauf s'il veut également
se suicider
pour laver son honneur
d'avoir gagné d'une manière
aussi honteuse.
Euh, non, non,
je préfère gagner.
Alors, on applaudit...
Le gagnant du tournoi !
Yes !
Bravo.
J'ai pas compris comment
t'as fait, mais tu l'as fait !
J'ai utilisé
la pression psychologique.
Je suis pas seulement
un physique, vous savez,
je suis aussi un fin stratège.
Donc c'était une ruse,
c'est ça ?
Mais évidemment,
c'était pour de faux.
Mais ça sent le vrai pipi,
dans ton pantalon.
Bah, désolé,
je voulais que ce soit crédible,
alors oui,
j'ai utilisé mon urine
pour faire transparaître
la peur !
Ça s'appelle l'acting, Madame.
Le plus important
est qu'il ait gagné.
Ouais, ouais...
Bon, allons retrouver le shogun
pour récupérer la relique !
Étrangers, vous avez gagné
le grand tournoi avec courage.
Non, je ne peux pas dire ça.
Vous avez gagné, quoi.
Tenez, la relique.
Ah oui, c'est plus
la relique ancestrale confiée...
Ça va, prenez ce truc
et cassez-vous de mon palais !
Et changez votre pantalon,
de grâce !
Ça sent jusqu'ici !
Merci.
Eh, mais la relique, c'est...
Une dague de petite taille,
mais d'une incroyable finesse.
C'est le couteau de la cuisine.
Je le reconnais.
Le Docteur Simon l'utilisait
pour couper les légumes.
Il s'appelle comment,
ce couteau ?
Raymond, Fabrice ?
C'est un couteau, Thomas.
Les objets n'ont pas de prénom.
Non, mais c'est pas que ça.
C'est le couteau
que je lui ai offert
pour la Fête des pères
quand j'avais 10 ans.
Ah, à 10 ans, j'étais encore
avec ma 1ère femme, moi !
Non, mais la 1ère relique,
c'était un cadeau de mon père,
la 2ème aussi,
et celle-là, c'est un cadeau
que j'ai fait à mon père,
c'est pas un hasard !
T'es sûre,
c'est pas juste des objets
qu'il a pris au hasard
chez lui ?
Mais non,
ça veut dire qu'il essaie
de me faire passer
un message !
Ça veut dire qu'il pense à moi
et qu'il compte sur moi
pour le retrouver.
Oui, enfin, je te rappelle
qu'il m'a appelé moi,
à la base, comme un père
qui demande de l'aide
à son fils.
Oui, et t'es venu
me retrouver après.
Il savait que t'allais faire ça
et que j'allais retrouver
ses reliques !
Et il savait pour moi, aussi ?
Ah, non. Non, non.
Il savait pas pour toi.
T'es un accident de parcours,
toi.
Merci,
ça fait toujours plaisir...
Vous êtes toujours
dans mon palais, là !
Ah oui, pardon !
Eliot, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Je fusionne les coordonnées
des reliques.
C'est bon,
j'ai décodé de nouvelles
coordonnées temporelles.
Oh...
- Qu'est-ce qu'y a ?
- On va où ?
Cette époque et ce lieu
ne vont pas vous plaire.
Retemporalisation immédiate.
Ah là là, mais où nos héros
vont-ils encore atterrir ?
Et que va-t-il leur arriver ?
Pour le savoir, il va falloir
acheter le dernier épisode
pour la modique somme
de 99 euros !
Hein, pardon ?
Non, il sera gratuit,
comme les autres.
C'est une bonne nouvelle.
Rendez-vous pour la fin
de L'Épopée temporelle.
À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Notre aventure touche à sa fin.
Iris, la Buse, Eliot,
nos trois héros,
ainsi que Thomas,
ont enfin récupéré
les trois reliques
et partent
vers les coordonnées laissées
par le Docteur Simon.
Je suis trop pressé
que vous entendiez la fin !
Vous allez voir, c'est ouf !
C'est... calme, par ici.
Nous sommes dans la banlieue
de... Melun, en... 1997.
Température : 17 degrés.
Pluie : fine.
Eh ben, je pensais que le futur
ferait plus rêver, moi.
Malheureusement,
ce sont les années 90.
L'époque la plus chiante
de l'humanité.
C'est peut-être ici, en fait,
l'infiniment moyen
d'Isaac Newton.
Y a rien.
Tout ce chemin pour ça ?
Pourquoi mon père
nous a menés jusqu'ici ?
Faut qu'on s'active.
Ça fait au moins deux heures
qu'on discute.
- Ça fait... 20 secondes.
- Oh, bon sang...
Ce lieu est maudit.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- C'est quoi, ce truc ?
C'est tout blanc !
J'arrive à peine
à ouvrir les yeux.
Cette déchirure aveuglante
devant nous
m'a tout l'air d'une faille
spatio-temporelle.
Une faille quoi ? Eh !
Y a quelqu'un à l'intérieur,
non ?
- Regardez ! En tout petit !
- Papa ? C'est mon père !
- On a retrouvé mon père !
- Bonjour, Monsieur !
Enchanté de vous rencontrer !
Moi, c'est Thomas,
le petit copain d'Iris !
C'est bien le Docteur Simon,
au fond de la faille.
Il essaie de nous dire
quelque chose.
Il nous entend pas. Euh...
Allez, on y va ! Sautez dedans !
J'adore sauter dans les trucs
que je sais pas ce que c'est.
À l'abordage !
C'est parti.
Les gars,
ça a pas l'air dangereux ?
- Allez !
- Tu fais quoi, Iris ? Non !
Eh, me pousse pas, non !
- Waouh !
- Mais qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est vraiment tout blanc
partout, ici.
Où qu'on est ?
- Iris ?
- Papa !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Et toi, KB-28 ?
Je suis heureux
de vous retrouver,
Docteur Simon.
Vous m'avez appelé
à la rescousse
et j'ai apporté votre fille.
Elle est comme une sœur,
pour moi.
Vu que vous êtes
comme un père...
- Et c'est qui, eux ?
- Enchanté, Monsieur.
- Je me présente...
- Buse. La Buse.
Je vous tue même pas,
parce que mes des-amis
me l'ont demandé.
Mais pourquoi la faille
s'est refermée ?
C'est bon, Papa,
on t'a retrouvé !
Et on a récupéré les reliques,
comme tu nous l'as demandé.
Quoi ? Les balises retour ?
Vous avez enlevé
les balises retour ?
Mais c'est pour ça
que la faille s'est refermée.
Pourquoi vous avez fait ça ?
Mais c'est toi
qui les as placées
pour qu'on les récupère !
Ce sont des objets
qui nous relient, Papa.
Des cadeaux qu'on s'était faits
pour prouver qu'on était
une famille qui...
Mais pas du tout.
J'ai pris des objets au pif
à la maison.
Des trucs qui pouvaient
ressembler à des reliques
pour que personne
n'y touche jamais.
J'y ai inséré des balises
pour assurer mon retour.
Et vous avez tout foutu
en l'air !
On ne pourra plus jamais
sortir d'ici !
Euh... quelqu'un comprend
quelque chose ?
La situation est délicate.
Précision :
on est dans la merde.
Pourquoi vous pensez
que je les ai cachées
à des endroits très précis
et que j'ai demandé aux gens
sur place de les protéger ?
Sans elles,
la faille se referme !
Je me disais bien
qu'elles étaient bien gardées,
ces balises à récupérer.
À un moment, j'ai même failli
faire la remarque,
mais comme y avait
des conquistadors
qui essayaient de nous tuer,
ça m'est sorti de la tête.
Oh, je vois !
C'était une triangulation
multitemporelle fixe
pour maintenir la faille
ouverte.
- Exactement.
- Astucieux.
KB-28, tu ne pouvais pas
le comprendre avant ?
Quand ça vous arrange,
je suis une cafetière.
Mais tout d'un coup,
je fais une erreur de jugement
sur un procédé qui relève
de la mécanique quantique
et je vous déçois, super...
Je vais faire semblant
d'avoir tout compris, moi.
T'inquiète,
je fais ça tout le temps.
Attends, les reliques
n'avaient rien à voir avec moi ?
Mais je pensais que...
Mais pourquoi tu m'expliques
jamais rien ?
Tu m'as jamais parlé !
T'as jamais levé le nez
de tes machines
depuis que je suis née !
Mais pas du tout, au contraire.
Iris, si j'ai fait
toutes ces recherches
pour trouver cette faille,
c'est parce que quand tu es née,
je me suis rendu compte
de la valeur que tu avais.
J'ai voulu maîtriser le temps
pour pouvoir en passer
plus souvent avec toi.
- Oh !
Mais t'aurais pas pu
tout simplement
passer du temps avec moi
dès le départ ?
La logique du Docteur Simon
se tient.
Mais je préfère largement
celle d'Iris.
De toute façon, on a tout
notre temps, maintenant,
puisqu'on est bloqués ensemble
ici dans cet espace vide
pour l'éternité.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Je sais !
On fait comme quand les pirates
découvrent une nouvelle île.
On repeuple cet endroit !
Non, non.
Je suis la seule femme.
J'ai le choix entre un pirate,
un robot, mon père et mon ex.
Alors on va rien repeupler
du tout.
Docteur Simon, voilà,
c'est pour vous dire
que j'ai traversé
toutes ces épreuves
pour vous dire
que votre fille est...
- Espèce de gros dégueulasse !
- Bah, la pouffiasse ?
Oh, fichtre !
Pourquoi c'est tout blanc ?
Dame Iris, dites-moi
comment on arrête
cette machine diabolique.
- Ach !
- Hitler ?
Hitler ?
Oh, putain, y a Hitler
dans une faille temporelle
qui vient de tuer Aliénor,
la reine du Moyen Âge !
C'est précisément
ce qu'il vient de se passer.
C'est vous !
C'est vous qui m'avez poussé
des centaines de fois
par la fenêtre !
Je me souviens,
vous apparaissiez sans cesse
derrière moi
jusqu'à ce que je sois expulsé
de cette boucle machiavélique
et que j'apparaisse ici piégé.
Je suis devenu fou.
Je suis devenu fou !
Qu'est-ce que vous avez
encore fait ?
Ben, disons qu'on s'est amusés
à pousser Hitler d'une fenêtre
une fois ou deux.
547 fois, jusqu'à
ce qu'il disparaisse du temps.
Sinon, ils auraient continué
encore longtemps.
Oh, le fayot !
Et ma fureur est 547 fois
plus grande !
Ich bin
sehr énervé !
Oh, putain !
Hitler en super-guerrier !
Bon sang !
Sa moustache
a changé de couleur.
Elle est toute jaune
et en bataille !
Mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez foutu ?
On est coincés
dans une faille temporelle
avec un Hitler démoniaque.
C'est vrai, dit comme ça,
on a un peu foutu la merde.
Jusqu'à maintenant, j'ai été
plutôt gentil dans ma vie.
Mais là, je vais être méchant !
Quoi ?
Comment il peut être
encore plus méchant ?
Admirez ce qui va sortir
de ma bouche !
- Boules de feu !
- Oh, les boules de feu !
Attention.
Courez ! Évitez les boules !
Enfin un adversaire
à ma taille !
Je vais m'occuper
de ces boules de feu
avec ma célèbre hache.
Nein !
Was ?
Arrête de renvoyer mes boules !
Sale pirate !
Vous allez être surpris,
mais je me suis
un peu fait pipi dessus.
J'imaginais pas du tout finir
ma vie comme ça.
Merci, Papa.
Enfin un point commun !
Fin du calcul.
Solution optimale disponible.
Docteur, j'ai trouvé
comment nous sortir
de cette mauvaise passe.
Regardez mon plan.
Ah oui.
J'avais oublié la machine
de la reine.
Si on prend deux machines
à voyager dans le temps
et qu'on fait ça... mais oui !
Bien joué, KB-28 !
T'es la meilleure machine
à café.
- Merci, Docteur.
- Mais attends, Eliot.
Pour réaliser ce plan,
il faut te démonter entièrement
et utiliser tes pièces.
Exactement.
Les machines et mes composants
serviront à construire
un vortex dans une fenêtre.
Ça peut fonctionner.
Quoi ?
Eliot... tu vas mourir ?
Je vais cesser d'exister.
Mais ce n'est pas grave.
J'ai découvert l'amitié
avec toi, Thomas.
Iris, je sais au fond de moi
que je serai toujours ton frère,
même si tu ne veux pas
être ma soeur.
Et Docteur, chaque café
que je vous ai fait
a compté pour moi.
Au niveau microscopique,
j'ai toujours écrit
"Papa, je t'aime"
avec les grains de sucre.
C'était mon secret.
Je crois que j'ai découvert
l'humanité auprès de vous tous.
J'ai cru que c'était un bug,
mais c'était de l'amour.
- Eliot, non !
- C'est la seule solution.
Je m'éteins.
On se revoit de l'autre côté.
- Attention, les des-amis !
- Attention, Papa !
La Buse, continue de l'occuper.
Je commence à fatiguer.
Ce moustachu
est sacrément coriace,
malgré son déguisement.
Y en a encore
pour quelques minutes
pour construire le vortex
à partir d'Eliot.
Thomas, t'as vu le plan.
Toi, tu restes juste là
sans bouger.
Eh bah, parfait.
Ça, c'est une mission pour moi.
Rester ici, ne rien faire.
Maintenant, je tire des lasers
avec mes yeux !
Mais c'est n'importe quoi,
il chie sur mon enfance !
Aucun Super Saiyan
tire des lasers avec...
- Ah, c'est chaud, ce truc !
- Pas bouger, Thomas !
Hitler, viens plutôt te battre
par ici.
Ach, toi,
tu vas goûter à mes lasers !
Ils ont le goût de la mort.
Eh, mais c'est une réplique
à moi, ça !
- Attention !
- Oh, putain !
C'est bon. Tout est en place.
Le vortex devrait s'ouvrir.
OK, ça peut le faire.
Thomas, tiens-toi prêt.
Papa, ouvre la fenêtre.
Ça marche ! C'est ouvert.
- Eh, Hitler !
- Was ?
On est là !
Juste derrière cette fenêtre.
Mais je n'ai plus peur
des fenêtres !
Nous sommes coincés ici.
Maintenant, Thomas ! Pousse-le !
- Pousse-le !
- Maintenant, Thomas !
Comme on dit dans ton pays :
adios, Hitler !
Pour toujours...
- Voilà !
- OK...
- J'en ai marre de tomber !
- Regarde !
Les deux machines
à voyager dans la fenêtre
ont créé un vortex :
Hitler tombe à l'infini.
Ah ouais !
Comme dans Portal.
On a trouvé quelqu'un
de plus cruel que moi.
J'adore ton père, Iris.
OK, c'est cruel, mais comment
on ressort d'ici ?
Attends, tu vas voir.
C'est plus très long.
- Waouh !
- Yes !
- Et voilà.
La faille s'est réouverte !
On voit l'extérieur !
Exactement.
Ses chutes et son désarroi
l'ont fait tomber ici,
et de nouvelles chutes
et son désarroi
ont créé une nouvelle faille,
et tout le monde sait
qu'une faille dans une faille,
c'est une sortie.
Une sortie créée
avec le seum d'Hitler.
Oh, le génie !
Allez, on sort.
Eliot, tu vas nous manquer.
J'ai connu des humains
moins humains que toi.
Allez, on y va !
Allez, Iris,
on rentre à la maison.
Euh, laisse-moi la machine
5 minutes, Papa.
Je vais déposer Thomas.
OK, mais ne mets pas
trop de temps.
Cette époque me fout le cafard.
On dirait que c'est le moment
de se quitter, la Buse.
Au revoir, mon garçon.
Parfois, les rencontres
t'apprennent plein de choses.
Et avec toi... rien du tout.
À part l'amitié.
Et je me suis beaucoup amusé.
Ravi de t'avoir rencontré,
la Buse.
Ne change rien. Sauf les viols.
Et les assassinats, aussi.
Allez, Thomas, on y va.
-Docteur Simon, la Buse,
je vous dis au revoir.
Thomas ? T'es revenu !
Bah, je vois que t'as ramené
ta petite copine.
Comme quoi, le physique,
c'est pas important.
Merci, Maman...
Iris, on va dans ma chambre ?
- Allez !
- Non, non, non, non ! Attends !
Voilà ma chamb... Euh...
- Thomas !
- Maman ?
Mais qu'est-ce que t'as fait
de ma chambre ?
- N'ouvre pas les tiroirs.
- C'est quoi, ces fouets ?
Et ce truc ?
Je t'avais prévenu.
Je suis parti combien de temps ?
- Deux jours.
- Eliot ?
- T'es pas mort ?
- Si.
Après, j'ai rechargé
une sauvegarde
dans une autre cafetière
et je suis venu vous rejoindre.
Mais on croyait que t'étais mort
pour toujours !
Bah, non, je vous ai même dit...
On se revoit de l'autre côté.
Tout le monde croyait
que ça voulait dire
on se revoit au paradis,
non, ou y a que moi ?
Non, c'était de l'autre côté
de la faille.
C'est vrai que vous,
les humains,
vous prenez beaucoup de risques
pour des gens
qui n'ont pas de sauvegarde.
En tout cas,
je suis très heureux de voir
que mon plan a marché.
Mais je crois que vous avez
des choses à vous dire.
Merci, Eliot.
Bon, Thomas, assieds-toi
sur cette balançoire en cuir.
Ah, ça pique !
Mais non, pas celle
avec des piquants !
Voilà, écoute...
Je sais qu'on a vécu
des aventures folles.
Ça, c'est clair.
Et c'est vrai
que ça nous a rapprochés...
C'est bon, je sais.
C'est fini entre nous.
D'ailleurs, pour toi,
ça avait pas vraiment commencé.
Je vois bien
que je t'intéresse pas.
Et je te comprends.
C'est ce que je voulais dire
à ton père.
Je voulais lui dire
que si j'avais la chance
d'avoir une personne
comme toi dans ma vie,
aucune machine,
aucune invention
n'écarterait mon regard d'elle.
C'est gentil.
C'est bizarre...
Je nous imaginais
vivre ensemble,
avoir des enfants, un chien...
Mais ça n'arrivera pas.
Tu sais, je...
Iris, Thomas !
Waouh !
Un petit lapin qui parle.
- Il est trop mignon !
- Mais t'es qui, toi ?
Iris, Thomas,
c'est à propos de votre fils.
C'est urgent.
J'ai besoin que vous me suiviez
à travers le temps.
L'avenir de la planète
en dépend.
- On a eu un enfant ?
- Quoi ?
- C'est parti.
- Suivez-moi !
Et dans un instant,
la suite de l'aventure de...
Non, je déconne.
C'est la fin de la saison.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
un cliffhanger.
Qui est ce lapin ?
Que s'est-il passé entre Iris
et Thomas dans le futur ?
Qu'est-ce qui menace
la planète ?
Autant de questions
auxquelles les scénaristes
n'ont aucune réponse.
Et ils sont pas dans la merde.
Pour une fois, je sais pas tout.
J'ai hâte de vous retrouver
pour la suite
de L'Épopée temporelle.
À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle